fliegermesse am Bodensee kam so Freunde
los geht's Flugzeuge
[Musik]
das Schicksal hat es gut mit mir gemeint
der mein alter Herr hat endlich den
Löffel abgegeben und ich habe Fett
geerbt klar jetzt brauche ich unbedingt
einen zweiten Privatjet welche sind die
großen Vorteile von privat
man bleibt anonym man kann fliegen wenn
man will man fliegt dahin wo man möchte
auch Fliegerkameraden ja
und Frau Scholz
meine Ehre meine Währung sie sind gleich
wieder in der Luft
so um zwei ja
Stuttgart
das sind von hier wie viel Kilometer
ungefähr Kilometer so ja das fragt man
eigentlich normalerweise gar nicht ich
weiß es ist eine Frage aber 120 km
fliegen sie gleich nach Stuttgart
Privatflieger so will es die EU brauchen
keine keine Emissionsrechte zu kaufen
Privatflieger brauchen keinen äh keine
Steuern zahlen für Kerosin da wird sich
die von alleine doch was bei gedacht
haben
dass die meisten Leute ja Treibstoff
also jedenfalls
einfach nicht mehr leisten darf
indem wir viel Fahrrad fahren zu Hause
elektrisch mit dem Auto okay
Dachterrasse
haben und große Pflanzen im Garten und
Photovoltaik auf dem Dach verstehen also
eine Art moderne Ablasshandel
Ablasshandel das Flugzeug verbraucht
ungefähr so viel so viel Sprit auf die
Strecke bezogen wie wenn wir einen ein
großes SUV okay das ist ja gar nichts da
steht man hinter dem Zaune und guckt die
tollen Dinge an die Flieger ja das ist
natürlich schon so ein bisschen Sie also
Flugzeug wäre ihr Traum
nee also ich Sammelbilder Bilder so
eins wäre langweilig genauso wie wir mal
irgendwie in Apartment in einer
bestimmten Stelle am Meer hat oder so
immer dahin muss anstatt verschiedene
mehr dachte ich mir sie sind vom
deutschen Wasserflieger vorbei ja das
hat natürlich den großen Vorteil weil
man spricht jetzt viel von den klimakern
zunehmend auch die Landebahn bedrohen ja
ne und sich da festkleben da haben sie
natürlich vom deutschen Wasser
fliegerverband kein Problem mit auf dem
Wasser kann man sich nicht festlegen ne
man kann es versuchen aber nicht
gelingen gehen
[Gelächter]
mit ihren Flugzeugen treffen ja das ist
wie Motorradtreffen nur in der Luft
trifft man sich und man kann seine
Haustiere mitnehmen
das stimmt auch einen kleinen Hund
könnte in der Linie auch mitnehmen aber
ist schwierig ja das stimmt also ich
habe jetzt spezielle
Haustiere würde ich mal sagen ich habe
einen kleinen Tiger ich habe einen
kleinen Tiger und deswegen nehme ich den
gerne mal mit an Bord und fliegt damit
nach Nigeria ja und zweimal im Jahr zum
Tierarzt damit die Zähne gebleicht
werden das ist die Welt erreichen und
der schön ich bin sprachlos es gibt
manche Leute die halten mich für ein
arrogantes Arschloch
können Sie das nachvollziehen
könnte ich mir vorstellen ja
Entschuldigung wenn sie so fragen warum
[Musik]
nach Hause
komm wir müssen Strom sparen macht die
Kamera aus Jürgen heute machen wir Asma
gefährlich
für die nächsten Schimpfwörter
sonst
setzt es was